flores damas y caballeros
es mi triste deber anunciar a ustedes la
muerte de mi amada madre la reina
se lo mucho que ustedes la nación entera
y creo que podría decir el mundo entero
sabes y empatía conmigo en esta pérdida
irreparable que todos hemos sufrido
es el mayor de los consuelos
para mí conocer la simpatía expresada
por tantos a mi hermana a mis hermanos
y el afecto avasallante y el respaldo
debería ser extendido a toda la familia
en esta pérdida
a todos nosotros como familia así como
para el reino
y esta familia más amplia en acciones de
las cuales se parte
mi madre de un ejemplo de vida de amor
de servicio
el reino de mi madre no tuvo igual en su
duración
su dedicación y su devoción
incluso mientras estamos en luto
agradecemos por esta vida tan
devota
estoy profundamente al tanto de esta
gran herencia y de los deberes y las
fuertes responsabilidades de la
soberanía que ahora ha pasado a mí
asumiendo de estas responsabilidades
buscaré seguir el ejemplo inspirador
que se ha establecido para mí sostener
el gobierno constitucional y buscar la
paz la armonía y la prosperidad
de los pueblos de estas islas
y de los reinos y territorios de la
commonwealth en todo el mundo
en este propósito
y que
ser respaldado por la fidelidad y la
lealtad de la gente de la gente cuya
soberanía debo cuidar y en
la descarga de esos deberes seré guiado
por el consejo de parlamentarios
elegidos
estoy profundamente animado por el
respaldo constante de mi amada esposa
tomo esta oportunidad
para confirmar mi voluntad y mi
intención de continuar la tradición de
rendir
los ingresos hereditarios a mi gobierno
para el gobierno de todos el retorno
de
los estipendios soberanos que permiten
oficiar como jefe de la nación
y al llevar a cabo esta fuerte tarea
que se me ha delegado
a la que ahora dedicaré lo que queda de
mi vida
ahora por la guianza y la ayuda
de dios todopoderoso
le pido el permiso a la majestad su
majestad para la publicación de su
discurso
aprobado
respecto de la seguridad de la iglesia
de escocia
entiendo que la ley requiere que yo
en momento de acceder a la corona tome y
suscriba el juramento relacionado con la
seguridad de la es iglesia de escocia
estoy listo para hacerlo
en esta oportunidad
carlos tercero por la gracia de dios del
reino unido de gran bretaña e irlanda
del norte y de otros reinos y
territorios rey defensor de la fe
prometo fielmente y juro
que mantendré inviolable mente y
preservaremos el establecimiento de la
religión protestante como fue
establecido por las leyes hechas en
escocia
en la declaración de derechos y
particularmente por un acta llamada del
acta de seguridad de la religión
protestante y la iglesia presbiteriana
por los actos aprobados en el parlamento
de ambos reinos
para la unión de los dos reinos junto
con
el gobierno
esos en los privilegios de la iglesia de
escocia que dios me ayude ahora invita a
su majestad a suscribir ambas copias del
instrumento que confirma el que el
juramento ha sido asumido
invito a los testigos
para que firmen ambas copias del
instrumento